I am from upstate New York I'm from
downstate New York I live now in
Brighton England and I live in London
now so how long have you been in the UK
13 years so I've been living here for 10
years and I've spent a lot of that time
working as a physics teacher in
secondary schools so if you're giving
somebody your phone number your credit
card number and you've got two numbers
in a row that are the same so my number
is eight eight four four in my office
the British way to say that would be
double a double four and it would have
never occurred to me to say it that way
I don't know about Americans in general
but I can say that for me when I moved
to London I was really thrown by the
double numbers thing for quite a while I
would say eight eight four four I might
say 88 44 but I wouldn't say double
eight mm I moved here there were two
problems what one is the double numbers
thing and the second thing is that
people say the telephone numbers in a
different pattern than they do us
numbers so it was that that different
pattern plus people saying things like
double five double nine I had such a
hard time getting those numbers the
first time and maybe maybe I'm just
particularly slow the thing that always
trips me up is I don't know whether to
say triple when I get three of those
things in a row so I had a credit card
that had three zeros in a row do I say
triple zero do I say double zero zero do
I say zero double zero do I say zero
zeros oh I don't know what to say I'd
love to hear from British people and
some instruction on how to read my
credit card number off the top of my
head I can't think of having ever heard
triple but I wouldn't rule it out I
don't I don't actually know perhaps a
perhaps your commenters can let us know
if they say triple another example is
what happens when you use numbers and
the thousands or numbers with four
digits the president's address
that's called 1600 Pennsylvania Avenue
in American and I think most British
people would be comfortable with that
being 1600 but when you get to a bigger
number Americans are happy to say that
is 5,300 a British person probably call
this 5,300 where I grew up on downstate
New York
pretty much everybody around me would
say 5,300 like for example I know that
that my parents will say 5300 but for me
as a kid I always found that a confusing
way to phrase that there's something
about it that just doesn't gel in my
mind and honestly it took me years and
years to really get that and so in my
mind when I hear someone say something
like 7200 I have to kind of think about
it in terms of hundred dollar bills
alright so so again if someone says like
5,300 I have to visualize fifty three
hundred dollar bills on a table for me I
always consciously made an effort to say
five thousand three hundred and set of
fifty three hundred which do you think
is more elegant fifty three hundred or
five thousand three hundred well five
thousand three hundred is easier to
understand I mean when I say fifty three
hundred I get confused myself whether I
mean fifty three hundred and fifty three
thousand even though I think that fifty
three hundred is linguistically nicer
right it sort of rolls off the tongue
more easily but I like the precision in
saying five thousand three hundred but I
was definitely going against the tide of
people that I lived around nevertheless
I find it easy to say that well I'm
thinking of numbers when I want to say
how much something cost you deal with
$100 bills in America like it's not rare
to come across hundred dollar bills
whereas I don't think they're yeah now
not a hundred percent sure but I don't
think that there are a hundred pound
notes that are actually produced I think
it stops at fifty and I have only
incredibly rarely in my life ever seen
someone actually use a fifty pound note
and it's always it's always remarkable
like at a bank I'll see someone pull out
of fifty so so maybe that's why as an
American it's easier to think in terms
of amounts of hundred-dollar bills right
I have I have twelve hundred dollar
bills so that's twelve hundred I don't I
don't know if that has anything to do
with it but that might be why British
people are not as comfortable with that
kind of phrasing the second year of the
2000s was 2001 for in American speech
generally but in British speech that
sounds weird
that sounds American you'd say 2001 so
2001 2001 this is one of those cases
where having lived in London for ten
years and in particular having taught in
front of classes and being very used to
speaking to British people all the time
I can sometimes kind of forget these
little phrases and and which way have I
always said it and and just naturally
thinking about it the 2001 or 2001 which
way would I have said it when I was in
New York I'm not a hundred percent sure
I think I would have said 2001 but it's
it's one of those things that gets kind
of lost when when you when you move from
one country to another sometimes those
little things can just kind of you just
become uncertain about how it was and
then you feel like a crazy person right
you feel like I should know how I used
to say things but you you just lose it
but I did I did look up after you
mentioned that the 2001 I wanted to see
how arthur c clarke actually says that
number of course 2001 he's british and
he says in interviews he says 2001 as
the title for his book is the way he
always phrased it I tried to find some
audio of Stanley Kubrick saying the
title of the movie but you know he's an
incredibly secretive kind of guy and
didn't do very many interviews about it
and so I I was unable to find any clip
of Stanley Kubrick actually speaking
aloud the name of perhaps his most
famous movie if you want to count out
seconds which people sometimes need to
do a typical way of doing this is to
have a word that you put in between you
numbers to make it long enough that
you've got a full second between the two
numbers and the typical way to do this
in American English or a typical way to
do it is to use the word Mississippi so
one Mississippi two Mississippi three
Mississippi four Mississippi five
Mississippi six Mississippi hopefully
it's about a second I've never actually
tested it I have no idea where where it
comes from except that it's a it's a fun
word to say and it's long so that seems
like an obvious choice to go in the
middle another way to do it is one one
thousand two one thousand which you'll
notice has a different number of
syllables the one one thousand
to 1,000 I think is found in both
America and Britain but then in in
Britain you've got other ones like one
Piccadilly to Piccadilly through
Piccadilly or one elephant - elephant 3
elephant I was trying to think about
this and I don't think I've ever had the
opportunity to hear any of my students
count in this kind of way that you would
do where you're intentionally doing
second so I don't know what any of them
would have said but the you know the you
asking me about this is basically the
first time I've ever heard about
Piccadilly or elephant when I said
one-mississippi two-mississippi that's
how I learned it with that very specific
singsong kind of rhythm to help you
count out the seconds and because I've
only done this on the blog I've not
actually heard people say 1 Piccadilly
to Piccadilly I'm not quite sure how
they're how they're singing it
Piccadilly I think is okay it has that
same kind of rhythm as Mississippi right
so one Mississippi two Piccadilly three
elephant elephant does not work I don't
think that works at all of it one
elephant - elephant it's it's so clunky
it's no good at all I have to veto that
one but Piccadilly Piccadilly seems
incredibly similar to Mississippi so I'm
I'm perfectly happy with that as a
difference but it's also the kind of
thing that I've found people have family
versions of that aren't used anywhere
outside their extended family so it's
there's there's room for lots of
variation we want to hear what word you
put in between numbers when you count to
make sure there's a second spacing so
put comments under the video
Mississippi Elephant Piccadilly thousand
certainly different we want to know
people often ask me or or expressed
astonishment when they get American
addresses that they need to send
something to and then the address might
be four or five digit long than the
number before the street so you know to
live it 2787 Main Street or something
like that whereas you know the last
place that I lived here was number seven
and my mother always found that strange
she often wrote it as 70 she just
couldn't imagine that I really lived at
a place that was only number seven and
in the great scheme of things it's funny
because I never really tuned into the
low house
thing I mean now that you have mentioned
it it seems incredibly obvious and yes I
can think of a bunch of addresses in my
life here that were low numbers and it's
definitely the case what well at least
it's the case in New York growing up
that I don't think there was ever a
house number that was less than 100 so I
knew people who lived in 100 or 100 107
or 109 houses but I don't think there
was ever a single address that was below
that number where I'm from you never
have a single digit you rarely have a
two digit digit street address so I my
family is on the first block of Miller
Street and the first number is 100 well
it's it's about the grid road system in
America in England you don't talk about
blocks the same way you do in America
because the roads are all
higgledy-piggledy and don't necessarily
make nice squares but since American
ones typically do make nice squares what
you want in the system is to have the
numbers all match within each block you
talk about the 100 block of Miller
Street once you cross the road that
intersects with Miller Street and go on
to the next block it'll be the 200 block
so my block of my street where I grew up
goes up to 131 and then it starts over
at 200 once you cross the road so your
numbers get higher quicker yeah it is it
is almost unbelievable to me that the
numbers on one side of the street don't
have anything to do with the numbers on
the other side of the street and I still
come across this and it's it's just
appalling right that's you're walking
across the street and the numbers on one
side are going three five seven nine and
you look across the other side of the
street and the numbers will be 50 48:46
right there they're even they're not
aligned and they're going in the
opposite direction and it's just
maddening I don't understand how this
came to be why anybody has let it stand
for
long as it has its it is just baffling
to me and the the first few times that I
ran across this that I didn't realize
like you have to check the numbers on
the other side of the street
I got severely lost in London a couple
of times trying to find places because
I'm walking down very long streets in
the completely opposite direction
thinking Oh Afghan I'll just cross the
street when I need those even numbers
right and then you get to wherever
you're supposed to be you cross the
street and you're hundreds off from
wherever you were actually trying to get
but you're still on the same street it's
I guess it's just unbelievable to me I
just it's like I refuse to believe that
humans ever decided to do this right on
purpose this isn't exactly number
related but I can tell you the the thing
that I did notice that I find is just
charming is the habit of naming
buildings houses right so even like a
giant office building will sometimes
have the name and it'll be like 70
Darwin house but this house suffix or
this house label for like big corporate
buildings or just council flats I find
is is kind of remarkable and very
charming in and of itself that strikes
me as being very British alright where
someone could say you know oh I live at
you know 50 Fineman house and but 55 min
house is a gigantic tower block right
it's not like a little cottage like it
sounds so I I do quite like that I love
to explore the city and just kind of
wander around and there's always a ton
of construction going on and in
particular in the past few years and
right now there's a bunch of big luxury
buildings going up or that have been
recently constructed and and I can't
help but notice that all of them want to
be number one at whatever they are right
so for example there's right one London
Bridge and there's one Blackfriars
there's one Tower Bridge right and these
are our luxury buildings and they always
write it like really big on the sign
right I'll say we have one Blackfriars
and the other thing that I can't help
but notice is they always like to write
out the one right it's Ong it's never
the number one
I find that interesting I assume that
that that's somewhere some architecture
firm decided that this is a kind of
luxury statement I'd be curious to know
if this happens elsewhere in the world
because you know as we discussed it I
don't think that it can happen in New
York because the building's can't start
at one right they have to start at 100
but I've noticed that some of these
buildings that label themselves as one
whatever they're in they're in like
suspicious spots where I look around and
I think I'm not sure that you can really
claim that you are one tower bridge
right there are numerous buildings here
any of which looks like they could be
number one tower bridge so I have my
doubts about the accuracy of this number
system although you know with the street
numbers you know who knows right you
know what's this numbers don't have
anything to do with anything so that
they could just be all over the place
you
so man walks into a bar he asks for ten
times more drinks than everyone else the
barman says now that is an order of
magnitude